[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre au match un mois et
demi après la prise à partie par des
supporters au portugal du malien moussa
marega victime d'un sur raciste et six
mois après les incidents homophobes dans
les stades français où en est-on
éléments de réponse avec nos invités sur
ce plateau louis georges tin bonjour
vous êtes le président d'honneur du cran
le conseil représentatif des
associations noires de france et vous
êtes également le premier ministre de
l'état de la diaspora africaine à vos
côtés rudy quasi éditorialiste politique
à france maghreb 2 fm et vice président
de la plate forme de pensée à politique
et citoyenne forces républicaines
bonjour bonjour messieurs avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet voici un
sondage qu'on a réalisé sur les réseaux
sociaux
berthe et le milieu sportif est il
raciste
oui à 43% et non à 57 % votre avis
messieurs ce que le sport est raciste
oui georges en fait tout dépend comment
on comprend la question si on vous dirai
ce que tous les gens qui font du sport
sont racistes bien sûr que non en
revanche est ce qu'il y à un racisme
systémique c'est à dire dans le système
la réponse est oui et cela d'ailleurs
dès le début même du sport
il faut savoir que lorsque le sport
moderne a été conçue par pierre de
coubertin au début du 20e siècle
son idée était de relancer la race
blanche d' affirmer la prééminence des
blancs et donc c'est un combat très
difficile pour les autres peuples
notamment benoît roux et pas seulement
de rentrer dans les instances sportives
et aujourd'hui la situation que connaît
est un héritage très anciens et donc
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un peu cette
ambiguïté dans les réponses et les gens
sont partagés non tous les racistes
n'ose pas de sport non tous les sportifs
ne sont pas racistes mais il ya des
éléments structurels très anciens qui
font qu'il ya un racisme qui n'est pas
seulement individuelle mais qui dans le
système même du sport
on pourra en débat vous avez des preuves
de ça parce que c'était quand même plus
de temps à ses déclarations officielles
de pierre de coubertin mais on va pas
remonter
à l'époque si vous n'aimez simplement ce
sont des choses qui ont un poids
aujourd'hui par exemple le foot m'ont
dit de la science un sport il ya
beaucoup de loire c'est vrai mais
c'était un combat et pendant très très
longtemps c'était des sports où régnait
une forte ségrégation et les mouvements
pour les droits civiques dans le monde
entier pas seulement aux états unis ont
fait beaucoup pour que justement ces
populations puissent être représentés
dans le monde du sport donc ce qui est
aujourd'hui une évidence est le fruit de
combat qui a laissé des traces
votre avis relie casier le milieu
sportif est il raciste alors
effectivement telle que la question a
été posée dans le sondage est ce que le
sport est raciste je pense que le sport
n'est pas raciste mais ce qu'il y à du
racisme dans le milieu du sport
effectivement on a pu remarquer qu'il y
à il ya une forme de racisme dans le
milieu du sport et j'en veux pour qu
effectivement tous les événements
malencontreux que l'on a pu connaître
ces derniers mois que ce soit dans le
foot ou à d'autres endroits
mais en réalité ce racisme il existe
parce que il y a des gens en fait qui
porte ce racisme
il ya des gens qui je pense que ça situe
surtout au niveau au niveau au niveau
des des stades
effectivement au niveau des supporters
ou autre mais parfois aussi au niveau de
certains dirigeants qui ne sont pas
affichés comme étant raciste mais qui
malencontreusement vont parfois par le
manque en fait de décisions ou par le
manque de bonne volonté met du temps on
va dire à m les mesures nécessaires
pouvoir contrer ce racisme mais le
racisme dans le sport en fête a toujours
existé en tout cas on va on peut
reparler du dernier cas en date celui de
zumarraga c'était au portugal
il ya le club de vitoria guimares le
club dont les supporters ont fait des
insurgés east à propos de montserrat
marega le club vient d'écoper de 714
euros damende mais l'action de moussa
marega sur les réseaux sociaux
il souhaite payer payer pour eux non ce
n'est pas beaucoup je peux payer
non c'est beaucoup je peux payer pour
eux voilà c'est ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il a réagi 714 là où c'est le prix
c'est le prix de la buvette
voilà pour tous les supporters qu'on
peut c'est le budget de la pub et de
coupures engagé pour pour la saison donc
concrètement c'est sais c'est risible en
fait mais c'est vrai qu'au portugal il
ya souvent eu ce genre de cas en espagne
aussi en italien l'a vu même en france
mais les origines même en fait parce que
c'est important de revenir en fait aux
causes et aux origines en 1904 lors des
idées des jeux olympiques a selon lui
les jeux olympiques ationale donc
c'était le troisième jeux olympiques
dans la version moderne de ddg haut en
marge de ces géo été organisé ce qu'on
appelait les journées de l'anthropologie
est en fait cela consistait à comparer
sur des épreuves donc olympique
dd loire et pas que des noirs toutes
sortes de populations vu comme étant des
sauvages à travers le monde qui
concourait face à des blancs sous le
regard amusé d'un band anthropologue soi
disant pour une expérience scientifique
pour établir la suprématie blanche sur
tous ces peuples et c'était le cas par
exemple de peuples pygmées du congo qui
au travers donc de cet événement avait
été encore une fois établie comme quoi
l'homme noir était inférieure à l'homme
blanc
donc en réalité le racisme dans le sport
est rentré de cette manière avec toute
une forme en fait de devis de d'image en
fait totalement fantasmé sur le noir qui
peut être un moment donné est moins fort
que le blanc ensuite j'ai eu d'autres
événements qui ont cassé cette image
notamment avec eux jack johnson
le champion du monde de boxe en 1908 et
1910 qui du coup a changé cette vision
que l'homme noir aussi pouvait être
quelqu'un de valeureux en tant qu' en
tant que sportif
donc en réalité ce problème
de loin et après il ya eu un basculement
notamment avec jesse owens qui a montré
en fait que du coup l'homme noir était
capable d'accomplir des grandes choses
sur le plan sportif mais ça s'est
transformé en un fantasme en fait sur le
corps de l'homme noir comme si en fait
le meneur finalement l'été préposé que
aux sports et pas sur les domaines de
l'intelligence etc et ont décrit un
symbole c'est intéressant parce que les
cris de singe sur l'emblème du racisme
dans le sport
pourquoi des cris de singe parce que à
l'époque de l'esclavagé
on a dit ce n'est pas un crime contre
l'humanité car ces gens ne sont pas
humains sont des animaux si une forme de
darwinisme évidemment de l'époque qui
consiste à dire il ya les animaux qui
sont là les hommes qui sont là lisieux
l'illinois recentre les deux donc les
cris de singe chez de ça vient de sept
représentations liées à l'esclavagé il
ya darwinisme social à la fermeté des
races
ça vient de là maintenant il est évident
que ce n'est pas simplement quelques
exemples là j'ai voulu faire un petit
exercice ce matin très rapidement j'ai
plus de 40 noms de footballeurs très ces
mêmes jeux pas tous les lire mais bien
par l'ama balotelli patrick vieira
samuel eto'o boubacar kébé et vertueux
min soo lee moutari dani alves george
weah le président du liberia j'en ai
toute une série mais si vous regardez la
chronique des dernières années vous avez
des dizaines et des dizaines de sportifs
professionnels
or aussi dans les clubs c'est comme ça
tous les dimanches victime de racisme
victimes de racines de cris de singe
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya une culture de
l'impunité car si ça se reproduit c'est
parce qu'il n'ya pas des mesures alors
justement inscrits est ce que ce sont à
ce que ça veut dire que les politiques
les institutions les fédérations ne
font-elles pas assez regardé comme ça
regardez la dernière déclaration a reçu
un carton jaune après avoir protesté
contre ces cris de ça donc c'est la
double peine vous êtes victime de
racisme
et là on peut pas dire simplement ce
sont quelques raciste dans le stade en
plus isolé
non puisque l'arbitré sanctionne et en
plus les instances sportives et les
clubs ne porte pas plainte contre
justement ceux qui sont auteurs de ces
choses donc c'est ça que je dis que
c'est systémique c'est pas juste une
balotelli qui a été victime systémique
sur le terrain mais également au niveau
de la pression puisqu'elle corriere
dello sport qui avait titré black friday
le 5 décembre dernier avec chris moning
également un joueur de couleur
la roma qui avait donc titré ainsi black
friday
comment est-ce qu'on en vient
ah ça comment expliquer qu'un journal
puis ce titre là dessus est ce que c'est
de l'humour à ce qu'on ne peut pas rire
de tout est ce que là il ya le rubicon
qui est franchie si l'impunité totale
honnêtement si ça continue comme ça
c'est parce qu'il n'y a pas de mesures
qui sont prises et non seulement il ya
une impunité des racistes mais ce sont
les victimes du racisme que je disais
qu'ils sont parfois condamnés au
portugal c'est hallucinant c'est à dire
que le joueur est en train d'essuyer les
crachats de certains supporteurs et au
lieu de le soutenir ce qu'il dit je m'en
vais c'est normal on peut pas rester là
à subir comme ça et au lieu finalement
de le soutenir dans sa démarche
on voit les autres coéquipiers qui me
disent non reste là donc il faudrait
qu'il reste sous les crachats qu'il
accepte d'humiliation alors que lui il a
eu la dignité bien sûr de protester vous
voyez que tout vous comme tous vos
coéquipiers non seulement ne vous
soutient pas mais vous demande de rester
à essuyer des crachats c'est là qu'on
voit qu'il ya un système c'est pas
simplement je n'ai qu'un individu est
justement de parler de système qui doit
et qui doit intervenir donc les
politiques les institutions les
fédérations qui doit faire ça
regardez la dernière déclaration d'
alexander schifrin le boss de l'uefa il
a dit le racisme est un problème de
société les gouvernants doivent nous
aider
est ce lui c'est également un gouvernant
avec son art fair in puisque c'est le
boss de l'uefa qui doit intervenir mais
je vais je vais vous répondre
en 2013 il y avait une résolution de
l'uefa qui tendait effectivement à faire
appliquer ce que l'on voit déjà
aujourd'hui par exemple l'arrêt des
matchs par les arbitres etc
considérez bien que sa date de 2013 est
depuis 2013 on n'a pas vu beaucoup de
matchs être suspendu par les arbitres en
raison de cris de singe ou de tout autre
type d'injures racistes vous même à
caractère homophobe non on n'a pas vu
ces choses là il ya quand même des
campagnes on avait une photo avec un
brassard noir bayern qui a fait une
campagne très récent ces dernières
semaines parce que je suis beaucoup le
foot et je chronique aussi le foot sûr
sûr sûr d'autres médias effectivement
l'échangé des fanions par les capitaines
ou début des matches mais ça en fait les
poules et râles également des cas bien
sûr en fait les jeux mais si vous
laissez là c'est l'arrière sérieux c'est
la balle hors jeu
mon propos c'est l'arrière salle en fait
de d'une culture marketing que prône le
foot depuis des années le foot est quand
même une usine de marketing maintenant
on a du mal en fait à joindre l'acte à
la parole parce que rares sont les fois
où des supporters ont été privés à vis
de ceux de venir au stade pour supporter
leur équipe
sanctionner les ou des clubs ont été
sanctionnés soit au porte-monnaie ou
bien des retraits de points par rapport
donc au développement de leur marché
sanctionne 714 ans va beaucoup mieux et
c'est évidemment pas beaucoup donc on
voit en fait que les instances
légifèrent mais par contre par rapport à
la mise en pratique des des mesures
qu'ils ont eux mêmes mis en mai mise en
place on voit qu'il ya vraiment du mal
pour aller plus loin et il faut en fait
que la société civile en fait prennent
le sujet à bras le corps via
effectivement toutes sortes de
d'indignations sur les réseaux sociaux
pour qu'aujourd'hui ces phénomènes qui
sont des phénomènes sociétaux commence à
déranger tout le monde
et qu'enfin on ait une ministre des
sports qui je souhaite joindre en fait
l'acte à la parole mais jusqu'ici les
politiques que ce soit les politiques
des instances du sport les politiques de
façon générale dans les états ont
souvent du mal en fait à aller aussi
loin que les lois qu'ils ont eux même
édictées
donc c'est bien aujourd'hui c'est
bientôt la poésie louis georges tin qui
doit intervenir aussi bien des instances
sportives que les instances judiciaires
lorsqu il y à des manifestations
racistes aussi public
on est surpris que le parquet ne
saisissent pas donc il n'y a pas
d'action judiciaire
donc ça c'est un problème est en
instance dans les instances du football
ou du sport en général
il ya des mesures internes qui peuvent
être crise qui sont pas prises suspendre
les matches sanctionnés
rien n'est fait à faire donc évidemment
les choses continuent j'ai envie de dire
la fête est gâchée
la fête est gâchée parce que les gens
laissent la fête se gâcher donc la
responsabilité elle est vraiment
collective
quand on nous dit en effet il faudrait
peut-être campagne à droite et à gauche
sympathique des petits plis mais les
gens oublient que le racisme est un
délit paris pour l'homophobie
donc si par exemple il y a de la
sécurité et des vols et des crimes de la
société on va pas simplement mettre des
petites affiches dans les rues rld est
envolé ce n'est pas bien non il ya une
police il ya deux justices qui font leur
travail
donc là sur le racisme non mais même sur
le terrain de foot doit être au dessus
des lois
matuidi
exemple qui a été victime de cris
racistes et de chants fin de cris de
singe la saison dernière c'est quand
même un élément assez intéressant parce
qu'il est champion du monde
il est vice capitaine de l'équipe de
france et dans ces temps de tourmente
qu'il a pu subir on aurait pu penser que
le président de la république par
exemple
et puis lui passer un petit coup de fil
pour soutenir sachant que emmanuel
macron souhaitait aussi table et un peu
sur la victoire de l'équipe de france
pour rappeler les valeurs de francité de
citoyenneté que cette équipe avait
manifesté lors de la coupe du monde 2018
je sais que dans la sphère de moussa
marega le président de la république du
portugal a contacté le joueur pour voilà
pour essayer de le réconforter par
rapport à ce qu'il a subit donc on
aimerait aussi que ce serait bien que
les politiques puissent aussi davantage
s'impliquer dont on en reparle juste
après la pause quel rôle des politiques
dans les affaires de racisme dans le
sport on en parle juste après ça
de retour sur le plateau de l'autre
match quid du racisme et d'homophobie
dans le milieu sportif on continue d'en
parler avec nous vos invités sur ce
plateau
louis georges tin un érudit quasi mais
si on était en train de parler du rôle
des politiques vis-à-vis de ce fléau qu
en est il exactement éléments de réponse
avec ce sujet à de pires matériaux fasse
un racisme nous grandissons les langues
se délient et les sportifs prennent la
parole pour qu'il y en ait mbappé il
faut se demander si tout a été fait en
dehors des stades pour résoudre le
problème du racisme dans les stades
discours salué par le délégué
interministériel à la lutte contre le
racisme l'antisémitisme et la haine anti
lgbt
roxana maracineanu elle se félicite que
les athlètes s'emparent du problème
la ministre des sports qui appelle les
instances du football à trouver des
solutions ensemble réaction à la prise
de paroles ambiguës de noël le graet
deux poids deux mesures pour le
président de la fff qui se dit prêt à
stopper les matchs pour racisme dans les
tribunes mais pas pour homophobie
si le foot est la première victime du
fléau les autres sports ne sont pas
épargnés rugby handball ou encore basket
5 novembre dernier match de coupe de
france entre roanne et boulazac
les arbitres sont prises à partie par un
supporter qui leur préfèrent des propos
racistes condamnation immédiate de la
fédération française de basket qui a
décidé de porter plainte contre le
supporter
voilà on vient de voir donc des
réactions de politique par rapport aux
différents faits de racisme dans le
sport
le journal le monde s'est procuré
récemment un document elles sont de
futurs projets de bois du ministère des
sports sur les dérives du sport alors le
spectre est assez large mais il y aurait
les matches truqués le dopage ou encore
le délit pénal commis dans le cadre
d'une manifestation sportive par exemple
en matière de supportérisme alors
messieurs à ce que le racisme et
l'homophobie vont faire partie de ce
projet de loi selon vous une charge il
faudrait que ce soit le cas mais je me
rappelle avoir travaillé à l'époque avec
rama yade qui avait mis en place ancien
gérant du sport c'est ministre du sport
et qui également avec des mesures très
utile contre nouveau faux billets le
racisme vous regarderez dans l'avant
projet qui en train d'être discuté c'est
exactement la même chose donc je ne suis
pas contre ces mesures
bien au contraire simplement j'aimerais
que les mesures qui sont généralement
mise en oeuvre de génération en
génération sera appliquée donc le
problème c'est pas l'arsenal judiciaire
qui manquent et loi contre le racisme
contre l'homophobie il y en a il
suffirait de les appliquer donc le
problème c'est l'application de la loi
car aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce
de jungle voilà au football ya beaucoup
de règles dans tous les sports il ya des
règles la seule règle n'est pas
respectée
c'est le droit voilà le code pénal qui
n'est pas appliquée c'est quand même
surprenant donc vous allez critiquer un
article un arbitre vous aurez un carton
jaune
vous aller insulter et donc violé le
droit français là vous pouvez continuer
ces mêmes vous qui aurez des problèmes
si vous protestez c'est hallucinant quel
est le rôle des politiques
rudy quasi on a vu beaucoup de
déclarations notamment on vient de
parler d'homophobie avec également un
noël le graet dans le sujet il ya six
mois il y avait des problèmes
d'homophobie dans les stades est ce
qu'il faut arrêter le match peut arrêter
le match du coup derrière un club qui
peut peut-être prendre trois points
parce que le match est arrêté et
séraphin ya beaucoup de gars beaucoup
parlé de ça il ya également eu avec
emmanuel macron qui a déclaré ne peut
pas s'habituer au racisme et à
l'homophobie sous prétexte qu'on soit
dans un stade de football vous disiez
tout à l'heure vous allez parler d'
emmanuel macron est ce qu'il aurait dû
appeler ou pas
blaise matuidi il ya des déclarations
comme ça dans dans les médias mais dans
les faits que doivent faire les
politiques mais de soissons moi comme je
dis souvent les stades sont un
catalyseur en fait de la société donc en
réalité c'est le réceptacle de toutes
sortes de choses qu'on peut voir dans la
société donc si on n'agit pas dans la
société dans l'espace public sur tout ce
qui concerne effectivement les acteurs
assiste enfin il est tout type de
discrimination de façon générale lorsque
ça va arriver dans les stades ça va agir
en fait comme une cocotte-minute et tout
va exposer tout d'un conte va dire oh
c'est pas bien ce qui se passe dans les
stades c'était un mauvais mais ce sont
des choses qui se passent dans la
société
et lorsqu'on annonce attaque pas en fait
aux problèmes à bras le corps en fait ça
peut être aux yeux de tous qu'il faut en
réalité c'est déjà effectivement comme
ça a été dit mettre en place
l'application de l'arsenal juridique qui
existe déjà et puis aussi travaillé sur
l'éducation
oui c'est quand même étonnant que par
exemple dans l'éducation nationale il
est très peu évoquée en fait tout ce qui
relève de l'esclavagé de la colonisation
qui sont en réalité ce qui a créé en
fait le racisme rappelle que le racisme
par exemple c'est un système en fait qui
prévoit en fait la hiérarchisation des
races qu'on vous suive et par exemple
des spécialistes du domaine ils vont
vous dire que lorsque les négriers de
l'époque
arrivés en afrique pour prendre des
esclaves africains il arrivait comme des
îles étaient des blancs avant d'arriver
et puis tout d'un coup quand ils
arrivent en afrique ils deviennent ils
deviennent en fait des esclavagistes et
les noirs qui étaient juste des noirs et
quand ils arrivaient par exemple aux
amériques devenaient des esclaves donc
en fait la perception du monde a changé
au travers de ces deux sets de 7
l'amour fait l'histoire elle en 2020
caisse vous faire justement c'est un
même c'est que cette histoire en fait
elle est ancrée dans nos dents de nos
sociétés je dis pas que tout le monde
est raciste mais des fois on va avoir en
fait des comportements qui vont
justifier le fait d'aller faire un bruit
de singe dans un stade donc si une
question au sélectionneur ne travaille
pas l'éducation dont le fond pour
préparer en fait une génération à mieux
percevoir en fait les altérités les
différences qui qui sont les nôtres et
qui en réalité ne sont pas tant de sacs
des différences parce que moi je peux
être noir mais mon sens par exemple peut
sauver à un blanc si on a le même le
même code sont garants voyez donc il ya
des choses en fait à faire tomber par
l'éducation et bien entendu attaqué de
plein fouet
donc tout acte raciste avant qu'il
n'arrive dans les stades
il faut pas attendre qu'ils aient des
cris de singe dans les stades pour
pouvoir agir et comment est ce que vous
expliquer qu'on parle de racisme et
d'homophobie maintenant en 2019 2020 est
pas moins mais parce que la saison
estivale on parle toujours
on en parle depuis très longtemps après
qu'ils aient des gens qui réagissent ou
pas c'est le problème mais vous avez
raison de parler d'éducation c'est la
mère de toutes les batailles pour parler
de sexisme et d'homophobie
qu'est ce qu'on entend dans tout
finalement dans tous les clubs sportifs
au niveau des jeunes et bien c'est on
n'est pas des gonzesses on n'est pas des
donc à partir de là il ya une culture du
être une gonzesse être un pdc - bien que
d'être un vrai mec une hiérarchie qui a
prise avant même que les gens
comprennent le sens de ces mots ils ont
déjà appris cette hiérarchie est
évidemment beaucoup de gens vous disent
ah bon on n'est pas des c'est pas
du tout court des homosexuels voilà
évidemment partie du monde à intégrer ce
genre de raisonnement
c'est comme si quelqu'un disait j'ai dit
c'est du travail d'arabe mais comme je
ne m'abaisserai pas en arabe
ce n'est donc pas raciste c'est ridicule
dire c'est du travail d'arabe
sous-entendu arabe égale mauvais donc
c'est du mauvais travail
tous ne comprend bien la logique rassis
de ce genre de propos donc dire on n'est
pas des sous-entendu pdc mauvais
on n'est pas des gonzesses
vous êtes nuls donc il faut vraiment si
on veut régler le problème prendre le
problème à la racine aussi bien que dans
les branches est à dire en aval lorsqu
il y à des actes les sanctionner et en
amont lorsqu'il ya des propos comme ça
prévenir par une formation adéquate qui
jusqu'ici est fait de manière vraiment
episode i par l'ailier sanctionnait
roxana maracineanu souhaite par exemple
pénalité dans le sport savez il y avait
une passe une passe d'armes entre roxana
maracineanu et noël le graet mal au
crâne qui avait annoncé qu'il
demanderait au service de laisser se
poursuivre les rencontrons d'éviter des
préconisations du gouvernement notamment
ce qui s'est passé en l'automne dernier
par rapport aux incidents homophobes
dans les stades
mais ce qui s'est passé depuis depuis
six mois et s'en passer est ce que la
pression des supporters finalement a
fini par exemple on est dans le discours
on est dans le discours on est dans la
façade de l'apparence par exemple la
ministre peut très bien saisir le
parquet quand il ya des actes comme cela
cela relève du pénal
elle peut saisir le parquet et ne le
fait pas pourquoi donc elle dit oui il
faut il faut mais on n'essaie pas
lui-même par le magistère la parole elle
peut saisir le parquet et où placer le
curseur entre dénis une forme de déni et
n'a rien d'excessif excessif
intervention cia 18 que s'améliora
qu'une condamnation qu'est-ce qui
l'empêchent de c'est un manque de bonne
volonté en fait je pense que le
gouvernement va se fixer en fait une
ligne de conduite liée à son agenda
ministériel dictée par les élections
enfin l'élection présidentielle de 2017
et donc toutes sortes en fait de deux on
va dire de remous dans la société qui
vont arriver en cours de route du mandat
ne vont pas être considérés forcément
comme étant des
des choses cruciaux le crucial pardon à
dos tiff sur lesquels il faut agir tout
de suite et c'est clair que par exemple
tout ce qui est lié au racisme et même
de façon générale dans la société n'a
pas été au coeur de la campagne donc
forcément le gouvernement n'est pas en
train de dérouler un agenda de ce point
de vue il n'ya que lorsque la société
civile que les réseaux sociaux que les
joueurs s'indigne et surtout que c'est
médiatisé que la tenant compte dit à
bastien en fait il faut le faire etc
mais en réalité tout ce qui relève du
racisme dans la société et même dans les
stades cdc des mesures qui ont été
prises depuis les années 90 notamment
avec la grande marche pour la liberté
qui avait fait son départ à marseille
passé par lyon et jusqu'à paris et
ensuite il y avait eu tout un tas de
mesures qu'on avait mis en place avec
même des nouveaux vocables lutter contre
la discrimination la diversité et c'est
quelque chose à faire au niveau du temps
européen elle en a parlé de l'italie
également la slovénie un joueur de
handball français qui jouent pour pour
les bleus qui s'appelle d'ikea même qui
joue pour le barça également y à rien
avait subi des insultes avec le barça
quand il jouait du côté de célia diallo
un peu bas niveau national ce qui
suffirait encore une fois de les
appliquer regardez je sais pas moi
lorsque il y a dix des problèmes
lorsqu'un problème je sais pas moi de
santé on prend des mesures adéquates
lorsque des problèmes d'éducation on
prend des mesures adéquates
madame chapa elle est la ministre
chargée de la lutte contre les
discriminations on l'entend sur le
sexisme et c'est très bien
est-ce que vous l'entendez souvent
parler du racisme sur l'homophobie est
ce qu'elle intervient pratiquement pas
donc on voit bien qu'il y a un sujet qui
est l'espèce d'angle mort de la société
est effectivement y'a pas de prise en
compte politique donc au niveau européen
bien sûr on peut avoir des interventions
mais déjà essayons de faire appliquer le
droit national
ce n'est pas fait et donc c'est ça le
début de l'action non mais déjà sur le
desk a été fait quand même un niveau ont
juste par la cei et une petite précision
quand même affaire c'est que sur le plan
européen
effectivement on peut saisir par exemple
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais ce n'est uniquement lorsqu'on a
épuisé tous les recours nationaux qu'on
peut le faire
donc ça veut dire que déjà sur le plan
national il ya déjà suffisamment
loi tu peux me permettre de d'agir
effectivement contre contre la
discrimination et en dernier recours la
cour de justice européenne où la cour de
pour les droits pour enfin la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme parlons
quand même de quelque chose qui a été
fait ces dernières semaines dans le
rugby le rugby français qui a dévoilé un
plan contre l'homophobie est ce que ça
doit va dans le bon sens à louis georges
tin quand même bien oui mais je rappelle
qu' il y à déjà plus de dix ans il y
avait eu des plans contre l'homophobie
dans le sport
les fédérations de rugby étaient
concernées elles ont pris des
engagements qu'elles n'ont jamais
respecté et donc moi j'attends j'attends
de voir je ne suis pas du tout naïf
donc c'est sur pièce qu'il faut juger en
tout cas il faut remonter aux
responsabilités c'est à dire que à un
moment quand l'arbitré ne fait pas son
travail lorsque le club ne fait pas son
travail de porter plainte par exemple de
forme et il faut un moment mettre en
cause des fédérations et il y à une
mesure très simple mais avoir des
nouvelles élections fédérales le haut
niveau et fédérations à l'automne car ce
sera prêts en lots seront vos dans les
principes à la maison deux des valeurs
républicaines
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continue à donner
de l'argent public à des gens qui se
moquent des valeurs républicaines
un moment je suis pour la
conditionnalité vous ne voulez pas tenir
compte des valeurs républicaines et bien
vous n'aurez pas l'argent de la
république et vous verrez qu'à ce moment
là croyez-moi lee clubs sportifs
prendront les mesures adéquates parce
que sans argent
y'a rien qui puisse se faire vous leur
dites vous conditionner l'attribution
des budgets à la mise en oeuvre de
résultats pas seulement de mesures mais
le résultat est là le problème est réglé
non pas il reste 30 secondes messieurs
le mot de la fin le racisme l'homophobie
est ce qu'un jour on les verra plus dans
les stades remy quasi écoutez je suis
pas très optimiste sur sur la question
sauf si effectivement on s'attaque à la
mer des problèmes qui est vraiment
l'éducation parce que toutes ces choses
sont ancrées on va dire de façon un peu
général dans ce qu'on appelle des
altérités ddd
des expériences vécues dans le passé
soit par la famille qui ont établi en
fait un schéma erronées sur la
perception qu'on peut avoir de certaines
personnes donc tant qu'on n'agit pas sur
l'éducation et comprend pas le temps de
laisser ce éducation arriver on sera on
sera déçu je pense mais sa maman et
enfin louis georges tin grassi c'est
comme la pluie je peux pas empêcher la
pluie mais je peux avoir un parapluie on
peut pas empêcher les racistes d'être
assis ou 10 homophobes d'être homophobe
on peut avoir des mesures qui protègent
les victimes si ça qui est essentiel
merci beaucoup
louis georges tin d'être revenue sur ce
plateau d'avoir répondu à nos questions
idem pour vous rudy quasi vous êtes les
bienvenus évidemment c'est la fin de
l'autre match spécial racisme
l'homophobie dans le milieu sportif vous
pouvez revoir revivre cette émission sur
rtl france point tv en replay ou en
podcast et puis on se donne rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de l'autre match bail
[Musique]